no right now Ben White is a better R
back than KY Walker no he's not it's not
happening no chance K Walker no it's no
way in isolated situations Walker shows
his quality shows his level because he's
one of the greatest but consistency over
the last 12 months Steve that has to
count and Ben White has been very
consistent and the thing is Ben White is
the perfect right back for Pep he's got
the build and he can step into a free he
can step into Midfield footall man no is
he peps a football man I'm going to go
Ben White because I think he was more
important to Arsenal last season on that
right side than Kyle Walker was to
Manchester City I know Kyle Walker had
some big games and he's a legend and
he's a legend don't get me wrong but I
think Ben White is very ver if you're
watching some I Tred my best kalker is
probably the greatest right back of all
time in the and you leaving him out I am
but this is based on this is based on
what happened we come back for the in
this was an all time if this was K
Walker if you're listening if this was
an all time you'd be in the team but
last season Ben White was basically
playing every game